as a mixed race person I like to be able
to stand up and say I'm very proud of
British history and we should all be
proud of our heritage without people
being able to point the finger at me and
call me a racist because when white
English people say that suddenly they're
racist for some reason uh yeah super
proud to be British I think that the
influence that the British have had on
the world is incalculably larger than
almost any other culture
um could please correct me if I'm wrong
um a lot of the Great Inventions in the
world were British uh the way that you
go to every single country in the world
and they're all speaking the language of
one tiny Island in northern Europe why
you know it's it's I'm a proud
Englishman and I don't care about the
United States so much because I left
when I was eight years old